rise of the Tomb Raider was packed with
forgotten cities and ancient tombs but
if that wasn't enough for you the
upcoming story expansion Baba Yaga the
Temple of the witch is bringing even
more to explore better yet it's
releasing next week the DLC is launching
for xbox one on January 26th just two
days before the main game makes its way
to PC the expansion is said to be
bringing hours of content between its
new items new enemies and of course new
tomb the official description reads this
adventure expands the story of the main
campaign with Lara facing down deadly
new adversaries exploring a new puzzle
filled tomb and solving a decades-old
mystery all culminating in a showdown
with an ancient and mythic evil includes
a new outfit and a new bow this isn't
the first expansion for rise of the Tomb
Raider and endurance mode released at
the end of 2015 and it won't be the last
either with another expansion titled
cold darkness awakens slated for later
this year when we hear more about it you
will too until then keep writing those
tombs and hanging with us at gamespot